well the already low water level at Lake
Mead expected to drop this summer which
will reveal some Hidden Treasures yeah
the race
of a sunken
set our team to reunite the original
owner decades later Brian will tells us
this incredible story oh my gosh
I I knew I I knew I I it turned on what
network it went I mean we went sideways
at 70 miles an hour another piece of it
Steve Buckaloo and his boat were last
together at Lake Mead in the summer of
1977. during a water ski Marathon he
pulled up with his brand new
custom-built 19-foot Hornet Super Sprint
with a V6 outboard engine one of the
teams that needed a boat and he was
happy to help with his wife Virginia
watching from the shore but during the
race things took a quick turn it
happened it was violent it was fast and
I I'm lucky I'd survived and all I saw
was a great big splash out there but I
didn't know what it was or who it was or
if it was anything and then about I
don't know 45 minutes later he walks up
to me and he's holding a piece of the
boat and he says this is all I have left
of my boat little did they know there
was actually a lot left of the boat
buried under the murky Waters of Lake
Mead it wasn't revealed until last
summer every time something shows up on
the bottom of the lake Mead we tell our
friends oh maybe someday they'll find
our boat well they found our boat 46
years after the accident here at Lake
Mead Stephen Virginia were finally able
to see the boat for the first time
what'd I say 37 years old I'm 82 now
almost 83. and uh of course I long
forgot it you know it's one of those
things that happened in your life uh I
didn't expect this but I was surprised
and always wondered what happened to it
and whether the divers actually found it
and moved it or what and you won't be
finding these two on a boat anytime soon
he would do it today if he could
that's why we just sold the last boat we
have I look at this and I realized I
believe God's hand was on me I mean even
though I was doing
foolish stuff
that's quite a walk down memory lane
Stephen Virginia planned to bring their
children bring their grandkids out to
see the boat soon and the National Park
Service said if you visit the lake and
you find something like that boat you're
not allowed to remove it or anything
else without permission from the
government